[Music]
it's the most free venice beach he's
ever been
[Music]
nobody wants [ __ ] homeless out here
man that's crazy kids are seeing things
that they shouldn't see out here
how do you feel about benefits these are
the companies that are looking at venice
with a close eye
they choose to be homeless
[Laughter]
you know more tents and more stuff like
that but honestly like people have the
best property in the world
we live out here where the beach if you
live in venice there will always be free
weed and food
what comes to mind when i say venice
beach
for many of you it's the beautiful beach
it's the path here it's the trinket
shops it's the eccentric people
i'm venice beach how you doing brother
you're looking good man like i told you
one day at a time man
keep it up brother i'm proud of you man
for real
you know everyone here pretty much yeah
man it's just um
out of the respect that i give you know
i treat everyone equally i don't treat
you as black white
yellow i treat you as human we are all
human that's what we got you know that's
where the world becomes
you get back what you put out right
that's interesting you know what's going
on out here og man
it's just what's the story of venice so
like let's say let's go
i know this long-term story but from
pre-pandemic
to right now what's going on
pre-pandemic it all started off when
their president mr trump um he started
to travel ban
we lost 60 percent of our tourist you
know
tourist crowd period so that stopped it
and then the pandemic came
and this is where it's just it's been a
downfall man it's been bad it's all bad
right now
now that the uh all hands off because
they have
can't touch a person's property without
a search one i'm like but
it has to be a property that you would
own i would think you know what i said
it's like you know this is this is park
property
state property and you guys are just
letting them run ragged now this
brother right here yeah all right i want
you to get him in
he's been out here for a minute how long
you been living out here on the
boardwalk
uh 20 years he lives on the borough like
those apartments right there
oh yeah with the little not in a tent
but on that oh
you know he's he's got a he's got a
knife i love the dog
what do you think about what's going on
out here
[Music]
it's the most free venice beach it's
ever been the most how
you feel about it i feel inspired
grateful
and it's ground zero for human evolution
so
the opportunity to shift and change
things there's a window
open right now how so shift and change
um basically
it's the wild west so if you have a
vision
and you've got the willpower and you let
dog lead the way
you're always going to be at the right
place the right time with the right
people in abundance
in celebration inspiration
you're an optimist i'm aware
[Music]
okay what story you want to listen to or
and you
become what you think i want to open it
up to
all of america it's the first time that
you can actually bring a tent
and legally be able to set it up and be
protected
[Laughter]
well that's the whole opposite of my
story i'm just gonna keep it real
[Music]
and then harry krishnan
he was basically saying the opposite of
what you were saying the whole opposite
i love him to death but um that was
[ __ ]
nobody wants [ __ ] homeless out here
man that's crazy being a recovering
addict you know
yeah seven years clean the lifestyle
everything from crack to um
alcohol crack marijuana gambling
sex you know those type of things all
the vices yeah
i didn't like meth that [ __ ] was too
much work what the hell are y'all doing
that yup
drop it like it's hot i'm there thank
you
oh it ain't the package i want it no
just kidding we're clean
and once the pandemic hit it's when the
police were
more so hands off you can check for
yourself you can look it up
crime rate has went up over 300 in
venice alone
a lot of people don't want to come out
here and the ones that are out here
are unaware like these guys yeah they're
they're they're blind they don't know
what's going on tourists they're
tourists but we need them but this is
the number one tourism destination in
italy
[Music]
but yes we want the tourism but we want
this [ __ ] cleaned up
for them to feel comfortable why would
you want to take your little girl
walk past playing camp right you know i
don't have anything against
homeless yep i feel that there are some
that choose to live this way there's
some that need help if you
if you look closely you see a lot of
people talk to themselves it's not just
the drugs
it's also people not taking their
medicines or they meds you know it's
people out here with serious issues and
they're just pushing them on the beach
and leaving them be
if you're down here you're good they
have a bus to come pick them up at night
when it gets cold
and then they'll drop them right back
off here you know
why would you drop them off and not
police them at the same time how are you
doing sister it's always good to see you
how
how do you feel about venice beats do
you love it as much i love it you love
it and where are you from
i'm from russia hey
[Music]
well she's a tough cookie don't give a
[ __ ] they decriminalize drugs where it's
not illegal i mean it's decriminalized
to the fact where you can walk around
with a
close to an ounce of metal yeah
yeah you know so to walk around and
you're high and you're walking around
with drugs you don't want to walk around
your people's kids kids are seeing
things that they shouldn't see out here
because the police are not doing their
job so what the police are getting their
orders from who right now
sid from the from the city you know it's
from you know
we have the uh they told me to get on
the council um
venice beach council i'm like y'all
don't do nothing y'all come out and
talk talk from what i've learned los
angeles is a very
sectioned off neighborhood like
neighborhoods and neighborhoods you know
they don't mix but by them being hands
off somehow the word got out where other
neighborhood comes out here
and then it becomes a gang issue you
know and then it's become more dangerous
and it's like you know
it's just well i'm staying in hermosa
beach you're fine there are no homes so
how does that work
that's what i'm saying we got a store in
homo beach also
yeah you know and it's like because
those you know
those republicans will well-paid people
don't go for that [ __ ]
they they don't not even
trying and i'm just saying why can't our
police be like their police
and not put up with him it's like you
can go right there to malibu you won't
see that [ __ ] there
not even this thing this doesn't exist
in malaysia oh no
hey yup you got it now
oh
either they don't know it don't show
or they don't care about us now you know
they know
because it's show so what's the last
thing to say they don't care
right out of the handbag even though i'm
mad at ice cube right now but he said
that
that's what's going to happen that's the
one because there's a lot of people like
this place been closed
for the last year the place on the
corner has been closed for last year
several stores down here are giving up
they're closing so
now they say you're not supposed to have
corporations
in venice beach but they let ben and
jerry's here they let
grand army um start starbucks yeah so
that's that means that law is no
non-existent that means you come out
here now now imagine
give it two years when the it's starting
to boom and nike say i want to store out
there
they can afford to buy this whole
building and put one pair of shoes in
there for sale
and just hold the building until it
starts to pump then all the travelers
are back then they say bloom
we're going to close this building down
for a month build it to a nike store
these are the companies that are looking
at venice with a close eye
saying we're going to come in and swoop
up and then it's gonna be third street
prom night
i bet you none of this will be out here
then
i bet you won't be out here so that's
the biggest worry for you small business
owners right
we're gonna get wiped out if if if they
keep letting this happen like this
and we and we start you know because
we're we're we're behind and rent a
little bit
not much thank god but enough to say
that if we don't make it this year
it might be our last year but nike's
just waiting they're like
you got a nice sized piece of property
we come in there and just
write it off love man yeah respect
your authenticity and your realness man
just keep it real that's all i got
you know that's that's a real um
attribute these days
it's becoming rare and rare to find
people that just speak their mind
you got to man it's like you got you or
you died you treat people as you wish to
be treated
every action has a reaction if you're
willing to deal with the consequences
behind your actions you have no one
answered
you stay true to yourself and respectful
to others it will show
and they will know i hope you got
something you can use man yeah i hope to
see you
okay i'll give you my channel all right
let's go let's go check out more of
venice here
how has venice speech changed in the
last year or so
honestly the biggest change is when
snapchat came in i think because what
happened was they bought up a bunch of
businesses
like local stuff you feel one way or
another about like money coming into a
community
you know but then they left and so it
kind of just [ __ ] everything up
because they
all the businesses are now gone or a lot
of them were
that they bought up and then like it
wasn't being filled so
why'd they leave i think they weren't
they had like a few bad quarters they
were not breaking anything
okay how about the vibe of venice has it
changed much or is it still the same old
venice
i i've been like moved away for a while
but it feels pretty similar
like it doesn't feel that it feels like
same spirit a lot of ways
like still very artsy community i mean
of course there's like
you know more tents and more stuff like
that but honestly like
these people have the best property in
the world so you know what like i'm not
gonna knock them too hard
yeah exactly
[Music]
oh
i will say california does a really good
job keeping its beaches clean you know
over there not so much but over here
no trash out there on the sand as
og said it's it's legit here it's legal
and nobody's gonna do anything about it
but this doesn't seem like any sort of
solution
you know what tourists are going to come
here who's going to bring their kids
here
as og said some people prefer to be out
on the beach where there are no rules he
was telling me
there are no rules therefore you know
there's no curfew
easy to do drugs easy to sell drugs easy
to you know
live whatever life you want if you go
into a home
uh or you know city provided housing
there are rules
and you can't live the same life so a
lot of this is by choice
he was saying and then once you turn a
corner
this is what gets interesting it's all
over
yeah finished
look at we got a nice grassy park
perfect place for tents
but there aren't any and it's basically
in that one mile stretch
and then obviously they're getting
removed from from this space
[Music]
just taken over here
[Applause]
[Music]
so what do you think is the future of
venice beach do you think it's gonna
okay
what do you expect everybody's got the
problem issue they're coming to the
ocean or next to the ocean side to know
to stress out to you know
relax you love it here of course
of course the homeless stuff doesn't
bother you or
some of them they do but what else we
can do
four days ago the outside of the
building is a glass
seven eight big glasses and in the
morning
i was gonna go to work i thought wow
they broke it
completely so we see that type of stuff
some of them they are all right
they are real homeless yeah they are
very quiet
very understanding some of them very
very very intellectual
but some of them they taking advantage
of the homeless
when the food is coming they're coming
it's fine
i'm saying it i mean they are not wrong
they choose to be homeless
because we have saturday sunday monday
tuesday
wednesday seven six days a week
food is coming here free food and then
some people from the malibu rich people
they bring them in the blanket
and brush you just name it i mean
they're for women and
man they give it away they give it away
tent
those people they take an advantage to
say okay why should i work
316 review
and the empty is coming free but you
should look at the apartment to pay for
it all the expense flashlights with that
responsibility most of them look at how
strong they are yeah healthy
it's strong so you're saying some people
are here are honestly homeless
other have mental issues drug issues
exactly and some are just working off
the system
yeah some of them some of the young
people sometimes i'll talk to them
i said can i ask a question say okay if
you don't mind tell me why you
why are you homeless one of them very
honest two of them actually says yeah i
used to be i mean
i'm i'm involved with drugs
and my parents they asked me we give you
a thousand dollars a month
get out don't be weird to the part of
the family
the parents give them a thousand dollars
every month yeah go yeah
get out of the home i mean you get all
that
he is a part of the icon
[Music]
good can i turn the camera on you guys
chilling yeah
definitely what's going on tonight
chilling
smoking trying to make ten dollars by
this guy's art we live
out here where the beach here on the
beach
there so is it like good community out
here
yes yeah well mostly the ones that are
bad good
don't go past roads like people don't
like don't go past where
rose that's up there yeah uh
we call it meth lamb yeah
don't go there don't go to bethlehem
well that bethlehem because that's where
all the tweakers live yeah
wow so the tweakers stay together kind
of yeah
there's a few tweakers down out here but
uh
they bailey are right there so what do
you guys want you guys want to stay here
for a while you think
i want to stay here as long as it keeps
giving me luck we are all
lucky okay you're lucky as [ __ ] out here
i have a quote to say
if you live in venice if you live in
venice there will always be free weed
and food
free weed and community people like yeah
feed each other
everybody helps suck it's light
people come out they give out free food
people walk by you
we mean well my friend has this in need
of weed sign he holds it up
people hand him twenty dollar pre-rolls
fifty dollar pre-rolls
weed right i'll tell you what though
right here
is sixty sixty dollars every time a cop
shows
yeah the rent is 60. you got to pay the
car every time
the cop shows up with the 60 dollar
ticket
it's 60 dollars hey but i'd rather be
paying that's
to live out here i'd rather pay that 60
to live with the tick
then pay 1.5 or 600 000 for a house
it costs too much wait wait so
60 dollars you get a ticket how often do
they come and give tickets
well there's one guy got three today
today today so it can get expensive
well if you go to st john's they pay
your ticket for you
they pay the ticket at the where the
shelter it's like validated validated
parking holidays
i like the way see you guys
you guys are making a lot of friends out
here with the ladies yeah
sort of what's your
what's your fail ratio
[Music]
nobody cares man you got the charm and
you got the confidence
driving a scholar in face you know a lot
of girls
you just got to pull the confidence and
smile at him you said he had a trick
last night right
yeah so she i kind of left in the middle
of the night came over to the other
ditch
but bro got to cuddle for a bit you had
a little cuddle time yeah
all right then she ended up sleeping
next to this one hi
hi
[Applause]
what you doing today
wow
all right guys good talking good talking
good luck with everything peace babe
who's og take care
take care guys all the best
all right guys we're gonna call it quits
here
finish up on a few thoughts
it's uh venice has always been an
interesting place
that has not gone away uh you do not get
bored here
it's stimulating and this homeless
situation is as complex and as you could
see from what i ran into
there's not one story you know those
young guys they're out here having a
good time together
and i think it's an adventure i think
it's like a
feeling of being connected to friends
others are tweaking out on drugs
others are i don't know all the stories
but there are many stories you can't put
one label to it it's gray
it's not a black and white situation
here like
pretty much everything in life alright
until the next video take care